die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen tragen im
hintergrund dazu bei
judith schnyder leiteten volk in laax
die an giuliano begleitet zugspassagiere
durch die ganze schweiz jan dolde putzt
hotelzimmer in luzern und sebastian
ogier vor ihm ist der jüngste
gemeindepräsidentin tessin wie leben
diese menschen wofür setzen sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und ihr alltag ein tag im leben der
schweiz
[Musik]
bellgardt in frankreich vier uhr in der
früh jan muss zeitig raus wenn ich
aufwache habe ich oft ein lied im kopf
er lebt seit zwei jahren getrennt und
hat einen neunjährigen sohn viertel vor
fünf im bündner oberland
die 52 jährige judith macht sich bereit
ich stehe morgens gerne früh auf dann
kann ich viel erledigen
am abend bleibe ich gerne auf aber dann
arbeite ich nicht weil ich dann alles
liegen lasse muss ich es hat jetzt
schnell schnell machen man braucht 40
minuten bis zum bahnhof genf wegen
seines sohnes ist ein frankreich wohnen
geblieben
ich hätte nie gedacht dass sie ein kind
bekommen würde
das war nicht mein plan ich dachte ich
will keine kinder
komme was wolle aber dieses treffen hat
alles verändert weil sie ein kind wollte
und ich wollte auch eines mit ruhe und
der tag der geburt ein kind es hat meine
ganze mentalität verändert
kurz vor 5 in walle die mutter ganz im
süden der schweiz
sebastianus 28 vor wenigen tagen hatte
geheiratet
er und seine frau wohnen über ihrem
eigenen restaurant in der gemeinde
bretscher
[Musik]
ich liebe das gefühl alleine unterwegs
zu sein
[Musik]
jan ist 43 und arbeitet seit acht jahren
bei den sbb seien stützpunkt ist genf
gerne wahr
hier steigen jeden tag rund 75.000
passagiere ein und aus als erstes muss
er die ganzen checks machen so tanzen er
morgen früh
[Musik]
halb sechs in brescia sebastianus immer
der erste in der firma seit sechs jahren
leitet er zusammen mit einem kollegen
einen forstbetrieb im tal
ich versuche das tagesprogramm im
hinterkopf durchzugehen und das ist
ziemlich dicht sebastianus gleichzeitig
seit zwei jahren auch noch
gemeindepräsident hier
er findet es wichtig sich politisch zu
engagieren
die schweiz ist ein land voller
möglichkeiten in dem jeder seine träume
und seine ideale verwirklichen kann
es ist ein land in dem die private
initiative gefördert wird und sich der
start um seine bürger kümmert ich denke
es ist eines der besten länder der welt
in der nähe von luzern
es ist viertel vor sechs die 26 jährige
tibeterin young ball macht sich bereit
sie ist vor zehn jahren in der schweiz
geflüchtet
beten gehört zu ihrem täglichen
morgenritual dass du hast die gläubige
buddhisten ist seit vier jahren
verheiratet und hat einen
zweieinhalbjährigen sohn
die sind nämlich lustig war
bis 7 ihr mann hat gerade ferien seit
einem halben jahr hat ja nun endlich
auch einen job und verdient erstmals ihr
eigenes geld
sechs jahre lang musste sie auf ihre
anerkennung als flüchtling warten in
seniorin bündner oberland macht sich
judith ebenfalls bereit
das ist zu eng hier sie musste nach der
scheidung ihre vier kinder alleine
durchbringen und hat erst mit 42 eine
lehre als verkäuferin begonnen da drüben
in diesem laden habe ich angefangen das
war der anfang meiner karriere
und jetzt ist er geschlossen
es ist so schade dass er zu ist aber was
will man machen
das ist so in diesen kleinen dörfern
dann machen wir uns auf den weg
vor einem jahr hat jüdischen volk nach
laax gewechselt und es dort jetzt
verkaufsleiterin
der weg ist überhaupt kein problem
man ist schnell dort andere müssen eine
stunde oder weiß ich wie lange fallen
dann ist es noch so schön zu fahren
die 20-minütige fahrt ist einer der
wenigen momente in denen judith ruhe hat
am tag
sebastianus schon mittendrin er nutzt
die morgenstunden um administratives zu
erledigen was seine karriere anbelangt
ist er erstaunlich schnell unterwegs ja
ich war ziemlich schnell
ich habe die gelegenheit ergriffen das
war zwar mühsam
ich habe statt in zwei jahren in einem
einzigen jahr alle prüfungen gemacht
es war schon schwierig und bemühten aber
auch sehr befriedigend
nach abschluss seiner lehre als förster
in diesem betrieb hatte einen
zweijährigen abstecher in die
deutschschweiz gemacht ich muss man den
eltern danken
ich hatte die lehre fertig mochte meine
arbeit begann etwas geld zu verdienen
und hatte überhaupt keine lust in die
deutschschweiz zu gehen
aber meine eltern haben mich
angesprochen und ich bin gegangen zwei
jahre lang bin ich heute daran denke war
seine wunderbare erfahrung
kurz vor 7 geht es dann im vallée die
mutter so richtig los am morgen wenn die
arbeiter kommen geht alles sehr schnell
es sind 15 angestellte davon vier
lehrlinge
damit sind wir der größte arbeitgeber im
tal seine firma macht größten teil der
landschaftspflege hier
die aufgaben sind verteilt zur gleichen
zeit in luzern auch young ball fängt um
7 an
sie macht ein praktikum als
zimmermädchen im hotel schweizerhof in
luzern
fast 38 millionen menschen haben letztes
jahr in schweizer hotels übernachtet das
ist rekordverdächtig
london muss auf der karriereleiter ganz
unten anfangen aber das ist ihr egal
sie hatte sich als zimmermädchen auf gut
glück beworben nachdem ihr eine stiftung
für junge mütter diesen tipp gegeben
hatte januar will arbeiten und die
chancen die sich ihr in der schweiz
bieten packen
[Musik]
rund 9000 züge verkehren pro tag in der
schweiz über eine million menschen
benutzen täglich den zug
[Musik]
janna ursprünglich pöstler gelernt aber
der kontakt mit den menschen und das
reisen macht ihm viel mehr spaß
neun personen 9 lächeln das ist cool
reisen für die arbeit ist toll
überall ist eine andere atmosphäre in
zürich ist die landschaft anders und das
wetter wenn ich nach domodossola gefahr
ist ist fast wie ein feiertag
wir haben eine halbe stunde pause und
können super italienisch essen
in luzern ist die umgebung wunderschön
und immer komme ich zurück nach gerne es
ist geradezu ideal
[Musik]
ich liebe ansagen auch lachs erwacht
judith filiale ist einer von 580 volg
läden in der schweiz auf sie und ihre
crew wartet ein zehn stunden tag
das brot ist das wichtigste am morgen
kommen alle und wollen noch ihr brötchen
oder etwas für die pause du hast die
preise noch nicht angeschrieben
dann mache ich das als ich hier
angefangen habe habe ich in jedem
regierung alles durchgemacht damit ich
weiß wie viel zeit ich brauche so kann
ich es auch von meinen mitarbeiterinnen
verlangen ich weiß wovon ich rede
und sie sehen auch dass ich mir nicht zu
schade bin selber anzupacken
darum stehen meine mitarbeiterinnen auch
internet im süden der schweiz regnet es
neben der arbeit im betrieb und dem
politischen amt führt sebastianus seit
einem halben jahr mit seiner frisch
angetrauten ehefrau claudia und einem
gemeinsamen freund noch das restaurant
lattek also in bretscher als er das
erste mal ausgingen hat er gesagt ich
bin sehr beschäftigt ich habe nicht viel
zeit und ich okay mach dir keine sorgen
man muss schon sagen in der schweiz
scheitern 50 prozent aller ehen in
kurzer zeit
ich denke was uns vereint ist die lust
aufs arbeiten
der unternehmergeist wir ergänzen uns
gegenseitig
und es ist schon richtig wenn man ein
restaurant unter dem gleichen dach hat
ist es schwierig ein eheleben und ein
privatleben zu haben
[Musik]
es ist auch schwierig zeit füreinander
zu finden
wir nehmen natürlich alle kleinen
alltagsprobleme mit ins bild sagt es und
ist schon wieder weg
[Musik]
sebastian o betreut auch noch eine von
340 wetterstationen in der schweiz
ich mache das nicht weil ich ein wetter
fällen bin sondern weil ich es gut finde
dass unser staat die alpgenossenschaft
die zivile gesellschaft damit beauftragt
ich finde dass es eine wichtige aufgabe
ist jeden tag den regen zu messen es hat
1,1 zentimeter pro quadratmeter geregnet
jetzt schicke ich ein sms an
meteoschweiz und jetzt sollte ich eine
bestätigung bekommen
ich bekomme zwei franken pro messung
vermutlich die sms-kosten und ich darf
auch jeden monat einen bericht über die
niederschläge in der ganzen schweiz
anschauen
manchmal sage ich aus spaß zu meiner
frau wir könnten jeden monat auf dem
sofa sitzen und kontrollieren wie vieles
in sankt moritz oder in puschen haft
geregnet hat
dies werde unter last es ist halb neun
ganzzug macht zwischenhalt in bern
[Musik]
merkte er einen unterschied zwischen der
welschen unter deutschen schweiz
wenn man über den röstigraben fans sagen
die leute weniger guten tag
das fällt mir besonders auf wenn der zug
nach luzern fährt aber es ist nicht
verachtung
es ist einfach eine andere mentalität
die menschen sind konzentriert in ihren
augen mache ich einfach meinen job
sie erwarten nicht unbedingt dass ich
hallo sagen in der westschweiz ist das
anders
die menschen sind ansprechbarer auf ein
guten morgen und reagieren auch
schneller darauf aber ob man nun auf
französisch oder schweizerdeutsch
lächelnd im hotel schweizerhof in luzern
gibt es jeden tag 100 96 zimmer zu
putzen
es ist vielmehr eine freundin von mir
sie hat sich 100 franken 120 eigentlich
das hier muss ich viele frauen weil sie
haben viel getrunken fiel gleich
gegessen was ist das schlimmste das ich
schon erlebt
überall kleider über auch essen müssen
wir viel putzen
trotz viel zeit es gibt aber wir sind
auch schmutzige auto die andere aber
schweiz es ganz ganz sauber müssen wir
nicht so viel putzen
asien gilt das größter wachstumsmarkt in
der schweizer hotellerie
allein die chinesen buchten 2017 mehr
als 1,6 millionen logiernächte
das tourismus paradies laax hat in der
zwischensaison nur gerade 1725 einwohner
dem volk ist aber immer etwas los
also sachen herumschleppen müssen wir
oft daher ist es ein sehr strenger beruf
guten tag körperlich sehr anspruchsvoll
man denkt immer ja verkäuferin das kann
jeder trottel machen aber man muss viel
wissen und vor allem sehr verschiedene
sachen halt trotzdem trifft es judith
wenn sie das zu spüren bekommt ja das
tut schon weh also man merkt man halt in
fehlenden respekt aber es gibt schon
auch andere aber dann denkt es auch sehr
davon ab wie ich reagiere
mein ziel ist es immer das wenn der
kunde den laden verlässt er sich besser
fühlt du musst der typ dafür sind klappt
es solche die sich total nerven und die
genau umgekehrt
sie fangen die negative energie auf
statt sie ins positive zu kehren
aber das hat sich ja sehr viel mit der
erfahrung zu tun
das wolle die mutter ist immer noch
wolkenverhangen sebastian ist unterwegs
[Musik]
wenn ich diese brücke überqueren bin ich
nicht mehr zu hause oder ich fühle mich
nicht mehr zu hause
[Musik]
im naturschutzgebiet kolumbianer müssen
wir dafür sorgen dass die böden die
richtige neigung haben damit das wasser
richtig abläuft
jetzt machen wir zwei messungen um zu
überprüfen ob das funktioniert wir haben
hier einen unterschied von 20
zentimetern ein becken sammelt das
wasser und das andere lässt es abfließen
trauerte nicht manchmal seinem alten
leben als förster nach wie er manchmal
vermisse ich das geräusch der kettensäge
ich habe mich dafür am wochenende aus so
viel ich kann
[Musik]
hauptbahnhof zürich es ist vierter nach
zehn jahren und seine kollegin veronika
haben bereits mittagspause die spd
beschäftigen rund 27.000 mitarbeitende
in der ganzen schweiz deshalb eine
cafeteria wo man richtig frühstück oder
ab 10 uhr morgens heißen kann
aber ich hatte genug von sandwiches und
wollte nicht mehr so viel geld aus
also habe ich begonnen mehr salate vor
zubehör es ist angenehmer ich esse
ausgeglichen
und vor allem weiß ich was ich esse
eigentlich hatte am liebsten ruhe in
dieser zeit im zug bin ich dauernd mit
siegen bis 800 menschen zusammen das ist
ein ständiger lärm ist es erholsam
mit sowas
in sebastianus restaurant wert vor dem
mittag seine hilfe gebraucht mit essen
ist vorläufig nichts
ich habe immer davon geträumt einen
öffentlichen treffpunkt eine bar eine
taverne oder ein restaurant zu haben und
wir haben es geschafft
morgens kann man kaffee trinken mittags
in aperitif nachmittags kommen die die
karten spielen es funktioniert gut weil
wir jung sind sie führen dass lattek
aldo zudreht der koch ist der drähte
teilhaber wenn wir hohe gewinne erzielen
wollten hätten wir in derivate
investiert hätten finanzielle hebel
genutzt das gastgewerbe ist dann
gefährdeter sektor man muss lust auf
arbeit haben und darf keine angst vor
der zukunft haben
mittagszeit im bündnerland zeit um in
ruhe zu essen das hat der judith jahre
lang nicht als alleinerziehende in
ausbildung hatte sie nie pause rund eine
halbe million eltern leben getrennt in
der schweiz
in 90 prozent der fälle sind die kinder
bei den müttern
ich bin morgens um vier aufgestanden und
zu lernen damit ich das habe was ich in
der schule brauche dann bin ich in den
laden gegangen und habe gearbeitet aber
die kinder geweckt zwischendurch sind
sie in die schule und dann am mittag
mittagessen kochen nachher laden und am
abend wieder hausaufgaben mit den
kindern diese zeiten sind
glücklicherweise vorbei
sie war mittags bin ich gewohnt ein
schläfchen zu machen
das muss ganz automatisch
[Musik]
so
12 uhr ist in der schweiz essens oder
wenigstens pausenzeit
die am ball ist mit einer anderen
täterin 32 prozent der mitarbeitenden im
hotel schweizerhof sind ausländer
bis um zwei müssen alle zimmer geputzt
sein
mit meine lehre als hotelfachfrau freue
mich sehr dass ich mein traumberuf
ich habe darauf schon lange gewartet
ich meine hier gekommen bin wollte immer
im hotel arbeiten aber wie kann ich das
bekommen das ist schwierig weil viele
die ich hier in der schule gehen
sie bekommen auch nicht so gut so
schnell eine lehre müssen wir sonst viel
gas geben und bissig allgemeine bildung
bekommen habe habe ich so stark auf mein
deutsch konzentriert aber fair zugeht
den tag im youtube zu lernen
spiel im youtube elend ja nun hat viel
vor mein plan ist in zukunft keine
bessere arbeit finden
eine bessere lohn verdienen das ist mein
ziel und eine bessere zukunft eine
bessere zukunft und schönes leben für
meine familie geben kann
das ist mein ziel allein hier jetzt ich
habe mein sohn du musst in ein besseres
leben geben
deshalb möchte ich sehr gerne ein außen
bürgern nicht nur für meine familie auch
für mich selber
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite des gotthards auch
sebastian o will etwas erreichen im
leben und hat es mit 28 nicht nur zum
gemeindepräsidenten sondern auch schon
in den tessiner kantonsrat geschafft
regelmäßig muss herum nach bellinzona
für politik hatte sich von klein auf
interessiert schon sein vater war in der
fdp
sein hauptanliegen ist dass man im
tessin wieder mehr eigeninitiative zeigt
und eigenverantwortung übernimmt
wir sehen plattner und von natur aus
unternehmungslustig aber ein aspekt den
ich nicht so mag oder den ich mehr zu
schätzen ist dass wir nicht an unser
potenzial glauben oder die möglichkeiten
die das tessin für seine bevölkerung
schaffen könnte
oft fühlen wir uns wieder calimero der
schweiz ein positiverer ich sage nicht
aggressiverer aber ein stärkerer ansatz
unsere chancen hier vor ort besser zu
nutzen würde nicht schaden
während es in der schweizer sonnenstube
regnet zeigt sich der norden von seiner
besseren seite
[Musik]
als ich jünger war habe ich oft in zug
genommen weil ich keinen führerschein
hatte und wenn ich die zu kontrolleure
gesehen habe habe ich sie
außergewöhnlich sie hatten eine gute
präsenz sie konnten mehrere sprache das
fand ich großartig
früher wenn die kontrolleure
reingekommen sind hatte ich die tickets
immer bereit die an ist immer noch feuer
und flamme für seinen job auch wenn er
sehr wohl seine schattenseiten hat
der schwierigste teil sind personen und
vorne
wenn der zug angehalten wird während die
leiche entfernt wird und die polizei
kann oder kann wird die leute nicht was
dem zug lassen
das kann lange dauern es gibt leute die
ein flugzeug erwischen müssen leute die
etwas wichtiges vorhaben in dieser
situation muss man sich mit dem
lokomotivführer absprechen muss schauen
ob die person noch lebt es ist mir schon
passiert dass die person unter dem zug
noch gelebt solche situationen sind
psychologisch im schwierigsten
[Musik]
der vor allem der tcs in basel gründen
schrieb
[Musik]
es ist halt 2-erfolg in laax läuft
außergewöhnlich gut
obwohl die anderen großen läden nur fünf
autominuten entfernt sind was ist judith
geheimnis ich mache während dem tag
zwischendurch immer wieder runden durch
den laden dann sehen die leute an
sie ist hier sie arbeitet auch das ist
sehr wichtig die leute schätzen auch
dass sie sehen dass du siehst dass sie
hier einkaufen
ich bin auch sehr dankbar dafür
das spüren die leute denke ich und dann
unterstützen sie dich trotzdem seit 1995
sind in der schweiz fast 3000 dorfläden
verschwunden
was ist ein dorf ohne also das ist nicht
nur die sicht als verkäuferin
ich lebe auch in einem dorf ich werde
auch mal alt ich will nicht alles per
internet bestellen und dann kommt dieses
päckchen und fertig ich will diesen
kontakt mit den leuten um 2 beginnt in
bellinzona die sitzung des
kantonsparlaments seit drei jahren ist
der bastian o mit dabei die männer sind
mit 75 prozent hier immer noch deutlich
übervertreten schon der fakt dass hier
nicht jeder rein darf erzeugt bei mir
emotionen
ich erinnere mich noch als ich im mai
2015 das erste mal hier herein kam und
ich finde immer noch das gleiche
die liberalen stellen mit 24
abgeordneten die größte fraktion im 90
köpfigen parlament sebastian ist ein
großer verfechter des schweizer
milizsystems heute morgen war ich in
columbia mit stiefeln an den füßen
unterwegs um messungen vorzunehmen und
heute nachmittag will ich hier um das
gesetz über den grossen rat zu
diskutieren
das ist für mich miliz politik wenn die
politik von menschen gemacht wird die
von hier sind und die die probleme der
bevölkerung selbst erleben dann können
sie ihren beitrag auf politischer ebene
für das gemeinwohl viel besser leisten
auch jan engagiert sich für die
allgemeinheit allerdings auf ganz
anderer ebene hast du gut wenn sein sohn
keine zeit hat nutzt er den nachmittag
fürs joggen er trainiert für einen
marathon und sammelt geld für
autistische kinder
ich habe glück dass ich in genf geboren
wurde
ich bin gesund ich habe einen job ich
habe ein fabelhaftes alles läuft man
muss nicht weit gehen nebenan gibt es
menschen die note zählt oder alles
verloren haben
ich möchte einmal helfen london wohnt in
einem vorort von luzern wallimann ferien
hat muss sie ihren sohn heute nicht von
der krippe abholen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jan holzmann ist koch und ebenfalls als
flüchtling mit seinen eltern in die
schweiz gekommen
kennengelernt haben sich die beiden 2009
an einem tibetischen fest
london war sofort fasziniert von london
ein kollege fragen endlich ein woche
nachhinein wochen nach 1 woche hp bietet
versucht dann hat es ist hier das
bisschen eines genommen hatte dann haben
wir so langsam angefangen zum reden bei
telefon
fünf jahre später haben die beiden
geheiratet
weil london noch flüchtlingsstatus hatte
durfte sie erst nach der heirat von der
ostschweiz nach luzern fielen
judiths 10 stünde ist bald um sie
rechnet ab obwohl sie ein leben lang
gearbeitet hat hätte sich früher eine
solche verantwortung nicht zugetraut
heute weiß ich was ich leisten kann und
dann fordere ich auch dass und das will
ich zum beispiel
aber früher war das nicht so ich habe
oft sachen gemacht die ich nicht hätte
machen müssen
für wenig so ist es vieles hat ihrer
meinung nach auch mit dem rollenbild in
der gesellschaft zu tun
männer und frauen werden nicht gleich
behandelt als mann hast du es oft
einfacher frauen machen er arbeiten
welche männer nicht machen
das sieht man im verkauf wir haben sehr
sehr viele frauen im verkauf viel mehr
als männer sind halt nicht so lukrative
jobs und ein mann
wenn ein mann etwas sagt ist es ein mann
der es gesagt hat eine frau braucht
immer viel mehr kraft um sich
durchzusetzen
jan hat noch etwas vor heute er singt
schon lange in einer band die proben
finden in einem parkhaus in genf statt
[Musik]
und was ist mit udo foht
ziemlich alles ist groß endlich eintraf
welche krise
ich hatte schon schlechte zeiten mit 18
war ich sehr nervös und hatte mit allen
streit
meine beziehung zu meinen eltern war
sehr kompliziert
ich habe mich in der schule geprügelt
nachts hat mich sehr inspiriert
ich habe angefangen zu schreiben das ist
mir geblieben
ich schreibe oft nachts das gefällt mir
sehr
[Musik]
in verbier
die
eines der lieder hat der damals für
seine kranke mutter geschrieben
ich habe dieses lied an einem konzert
gespielt das hat mir gut getan und es
gab leute die am ende des konzertes sehr
bewegt waren und zu mir kamen um ihr zu
sagen dass dieses lied sie sehr
anspricht
ich dachte das ist großartig mit eigenen
worten eigenen gefühlen kann man etwas
teile mit anderen etwas gemeinsam haben
die freude an der musik teilte aber vor
allem auch mit den anderen
bandmitgliedern die teilnehmer etwas
großartiges
mein leben ist er immer teilen das ist
super singen macht mich leer
aber es erfüllt mich auch mit emotionen
und es bringt mich dazu weiterzumachen
[Musik]
london sitzt ihre vergangenheit immer
noch in den knochen
sie wurde nach einer demonstration von
der polizei verfolgt ihre eltern haben
je zur flucht verholfen hat sich ganz
allein auf den weg gemacht
mit weil das unterstützt mir unter weg
auf dem berg das soll einfach glauben
und ich hab das immer mit mir es
schwieriger von teenagern habe ich zu
fuß gegangen ist ausgeführt auge und
dann von booten bis nepal nicht so
schlimm weil es gibt fällt es etwa im
nebel ein paar monaten da und dann von
da bin ich bin hierher gekommen mit der
hilfe von einem mann als ich mit ihm
ausgekommen bin hat die wickel große
angst weil ich kenne diesen mann könig
und ffo blonde haare mit gesehen und
dass er komisch für mich auch und aber
meine diese familie hat mir gesagt du
musst von hier aus geht sowieso bist du
hier illegal
ich hatte keine anderen welt ich halte
kannst du hier oder hier werden durch
gegessen wie es dem gefängnis sein
dann müsst ihr das gewebe nicht aber ist
auch gehen dagegen mit ihm egal was
passiert ich habe ganze ganze unterricht
nur gebetet
um halb acht insignia judith hat
feierabend
früher war immer viel betrieb in ihrem
haus jetzt wohnen fünf katzen und nur
noch das jüngste von vier kindern hier
sie und ihre tochter geben sich heute
praktisch die klinke in die hand
auch judith muss schon bald wieder los
sie ist im dorf als präsidentin des
samaritervereins sehr engagiert und
hilft auch in frauen verein mit zudem
macht sie musik
die proben beginnen am 8
[Musik]
sebastian hat es knapp auf die nächste
sitzung zurück in seine gemeinde
bretscher geschafft gut guten abend alle
zusammen
wir können unsere übliche gemeinde
sitzung beginnen
ich möchte sie höflich bitten das zimmer
zu verlassen
[Musik]
judith musikprobe sie spielt gleich in
zweidorf musiken und singt noch im
kirchenchor mit drei abende pro woche
sind so bereits verbucht viele
engagieren sich halt nicht oder wollen
nur konsumieren etwas machen ist immer
schwieriger man kann dann auch etwas
falsch machen aber man macht wenigstens
etwas
das versuche ich ein bisschen vorzuleben
vielleicht macht es ja der eine oder
andere nach in der dorfmusik somit
kompatibel machen auch zwei ihrer söhne
mit danny dirigiert ich genieße das
michi spielt schlagzeug wir sind so
wenige momente zusammen
aber diesen moment haben wir zusammen
pause
[Gelächter]
in luzern young boys mit ihrer kleinen
familie den feierabend ihr ist es recht
wenn nicht viel läuft
[Gelächter]
hauptsache sie können zeit miteinander
verbringen
mein mann mein sohn die mir unterstützen
können und bis jetzt läuft sehr gut und
nach noch 1 2567 fertig gespielt
um halb neun ist nachtruhe für die ganze
familie
london muss morgen um halb sechs wieder
raus
es nachts ein im bündnerland
bei einem bier in der dorfbeiz lässt den
tag ausklingen
jan ist ausgepowert aber zufrieden
morgen muss er wieder früh raus
[Musik]
morgen muss ich um drei uhr aufstehen
dann geht's nach italien
[Musik]
sogar sebastian kommt endlich zur ruhe
in seinem restaurant hat seine frau noch
etwas essen für ihn beiseite gestellt
[Musik]
jetzt ist es 20 nach mitternacht davon
habe ich immer geträumt nach hause
kommen müde von der arbeit ohne das
gefühl zu haben dass ich nicht alles
getan habe was ich hätte tun können
ich denke das ist das beste was du dir
wünschen kann
ein tag im leben der schweiz geht zu
ende
morgen stehen sie wieder auf und mit
ihnen mehr als acht millionen andere
menschen in der schweiz jeder mit seinem
alltag und mit seiner geschichte nächste
woche kurt fischer [ __ ] kamine im
mittelland valentina andere produziert
biowein in wallis alex bosl steuert
dampfschiffe über den genfer see
und perry jost betreut kinder in einem
zürcher hort